[Rapid beeping]
[Ding]
LOKI
[Grunts]
I know what this place is.
♪♪
The timekeepers have
built quite the circus.
And I see the clowns are playing
their parts to perfection.
MOBIUS
Big metaphor guy. I love it.
Makes you sound
super smart.
LOKI
I am smart.
MOBIUS
I know.
LOKI
Okay.
MOBIUS
LOKI
[Screaming]
TVA AGENT
Please sign to verify
this is everything
you've ever said.
LOKI
This is absurd.
[Printer prints out a page]
TVA AGENT
Sign this too.
♪♪
MOBIUS
We protect the proper flow of time.
You picked up the Tesseract,
breaking reality.
I want you to
help us fix it.
LOKI
Why me?
MOBIUS
I need your unique Loki perspective.
LOKI
Do I get a weapon?
MOBIUS
Nah.
♪♪
TVA JUDGE
You really believe in this Loki variant?
MOBIUS
Luckily, he believes in himself enough
for the both of us.
LOKI
Bye.
It is adorable, that you
think you could possibly...
...manipulate me.
LOKI
I'm ten steps ahead of you.
MOBIUS
You're not big on trust, are you?
♪♪
LOKI
You can trust me.
MOBIUS
Loki, I have studied almost every moment
of your entire life.
You've literally stabbed
people in the back like fifty times.
LOKI
Well, I'd never do it again!
♪♪